-Trying to sneak up on me?
-Maybe.
You're a badass.
I will never choose
to be with you.
Wait, you wanna go
inside my head?
What's up? I'm Gabe.
Kraft service?
Oh, yeah, sorry.
Gabe is new to Matheson too.
We were on a frantic search
for our monster,
so we offered him friendship
in exchange
for wearing a suit
that doesn't breathe.
It does not
smell awesome in here.
You're a badass.
I don't feel like a badass.
I like this, Kinsey.
What does my family have
no one else
in the world does?
Like 19 chimneys.
No.
Oh, you mean
like magical keys?
Yeah.
How did they--
I mean, I, I thought that
hardly anyone
knew about those?
That may be a story
for another day.
Your secret's safe with me,
I hope you know that.
-I do.
-Hey!
Welcome to the upper class.
-You're in a good mood.
-Why wouldn't I be?
We're juniors now
and we got
a partial standing ovation
for premiering
what has gotta be
the second best
lobster movie of all time.
What's the first best?
The lobster.
There aren't any lobsters
in that movie.
Okay, so then we win!
And to celebrate,
I got us dinner reservations
for tonight at Stan's Pizza.
I didn't know Stan's
even took reservations.
Usually they don't,
but they made an exception
for a high roller
such as myself.
Know that sticky table
next to the dart board?
-That's all ours.
-Oh.
How could a girl
say no to that?
Speaking of,
do you ever think about,
you know,
how the keys were made?
Where they came from?
I told you
my ancestors made them.
I know,
but maybe you inherited
some sense of how to do it?
How to make new keys?
How to melt down metal
and somehow infuse it
with magical power?
I don't think so. Sorry.
I'm pretty curious
about your family too.
My family?
Have a special connection
to being really boring.
You feel
like you know me, right?
Sure.
Wait, it's, um...
uh, it's Kinsey, right?
I'm serious.
Wait, you wanna go
inside my head?
Uh...
I, uh, I dunno, Kinsey.
That's kinda...
I dunno. It-it's probably
a mess up there.
I don't care. Whatever it is
it's part of you.
It's nothing personal.
Don't think
I'm ready for that.
How could this
not be personal?
Because it's,
it's not about you.
Gabe, I promise.
I would never judge you--
No! No! Just drop it!
Sure.
Hmm, trouble in paradise?
Shut up, Eden.
She doesn't know how
to make keys.
Ah...
that's too bad.
Oh, silver lining.
We can kill her now.
No.
Chill.
Oh, shit.
He knows
that you made a key.
It's why he cares so much
about fixing you.
Why's he not making a grab
for me right now?
Because I lied to him.
He doesn't know you've had
your memory restored.
And we have to keep it
that way.
Until we can
come up with a plan.
Gabe!
What're you doing here?
You know, I just,
I left my bike here
and so I thought
I'd just check in.
how's Duncan?
Does he remember?
No.
We tried the key,
but it didn't work.
What happened?
Is he okay?
Uh, no. not at all.
He's resting.
I'm, I'm so sorry that...
that must be
really disappointing.
Is there anything I can--
-I can stay for a while--
-Hey, man.
This isn't a good time.
I'll see you guys tomorrow
and Winter Fest, right?
Course.
Text me
if you need anything.
Maybe it's just gonna
take some time.
So, what're you doing today?
Did you volunteer
to work a booth?
No, no. I actually thought
I'd come
and keep you company.
Maybe get my face painted
if there's not an age limit.
How about
this little lobster claw
in honour of my boy,
Nephropida.
This'll only hurt a little.
If Erin knew,
then they know too.
Really think if Kinsey knew
she'd sit across from me
painting butterflies
all day?
Well, then explain Duncan.
I saw Duncan use
the Anywhere key.
He remembers magic.
Let's face it,
you got played.
Don't you think Amanda
should take
Nephropida's hand here?
Uh... yeah. I like that.
Yeah, sure.
-You bitch!
-Stop!
Tyler!
Guess we're doing this
the hard way.
Stop!
-Hey, Kins.
-What do you want from me?
Isn't that obvious?
I want you to join me.
I will never chose
to be with you.
Or be like you!
Fine.
Then I'll kill your mum.
Yeah, Nina.
And just to be clear,
not turn her...
I mean kill her.
Hey.
If I'm being honest,
I didn't expect you
to show up.
Here I am.
You want me
to want to join you,
voluntarily.
But you've trapped me.
You've made it so I don't
have any other choice.
Kinsey. Whatever I am,
I still have a human soul.
I meant what I said.
You seriously think
you love me?
If I didn't,
you'd already be dead
That's never gonna happen.
Because I realised
one thing
I can still control
is my own fate.
Are you kidding me!
Why couldn't you
just done what I wanted?
Goodbye. Kinsey.
Kinsey!
Holy shit,
You made it! I can't even...